[Музика]
гм
привіт 9 клас мене звати Анна і ось
сьогодні урок англійської мови
у нас на
уроці буде учень, його звуть максим так
привіт, максим, привіт як справи  у тебе все
добре, дякую,
як справи, я теж дуже дякую,
як пройшов твій ранок сьогодні
було добре, я вже мав біологічний
урок, і він був дуже інформативним, і
це було приємно, і я з нетерпінням чекаю
цього уроку
.  дуже добре, добре, ви також
скажете кілька слів про себе,
представте себе нашим глядачам,
ну, мене звати Макс, я пілот,
я літаю на комерційних літаках Boeing 737,
а
також я льотний інструктор, я навчаю
людей літати
і так, мені це подобається, це дуже
чудово, чи
можна сказати, що твоя робота - це твоє хобі
або твоє хобі стало твоєю роботою,
я хотів би сказати, що це була моя
мрія, і
моя мрія стала моїм хобі,
а потім стала моєю  е, життєва ціль
, щоб зробити це моєю професією
, і врешті-решт я цього досяг  Я
дуже радий це зробити
переглянути деякий словниковий запас, щоб загалом, які види
хобі
ви знаєте, які
ви можете назвати, наприклад,
мені подобається добре читати, а я теж люблю читати,
і зазвичай у мене немає часу
читати щось на
кшталт документальних фільмів чи
інших  типи літератури, але тому що
мені доводиться
вивчати багато технічних матеріалів
щодо літаків і всіх
нормативних матеріалів для льотної
школи тощо,
але коли я маю час, особливо зараз,
я маю час почитати деякі книги,
тому не так багато
чесно кажучи добре, але я добре намагаюся,
які у вас є ще хобі або, можливо
, взагалі, які хобі
ви б хотіли зайняти
я намагаюся займатися спортом, коли у мене є вільний
час, я люблю
активний відпочинок, тому  я проводжу час у тренажерному залі,
зараз у нас немає тренажерного залу, тому я намагаюся
займатися вдома,
я тренуюсь вдома, я також іноді бігаю на свіжому повітрі
і просто роблю регулярні
штанги для підборіддя
та трохи спортивної сумки тощо
круто  так, добре, дуже дякую, що
поділилися, зараз давайте подивимося на
дошку, а
тут ви можете побачити список
найпоширеніших хобі,
якими молоді люди
зазвичай займаються і займаються у своєму житті не лише молодими людьми,
тож давайте подивимось і  хм, ви можете розповісти
про
деякі хобі щось
цікаве, можливо, щось, чим ви
хотіли б спробувати зайнятися,
або щось, що ви пробували у своєму
житті, наприклад,
ігри чи модне плавання, судячись із
малюванням, мені подобається музика,
усе, що я роблю, я роблю з музикою
навіть навчаюся, я також займаюся музикою,
як я вже сказав, я багато читаю, е-е-е,
наче це технічні речі або що-небудь, що
я роблю, слухаючи музику, е-е,
мені подобається спорт, а також мені
подобається плавати, футбол,
біг, також
що ще  чи там мені все одно
я не граю в комп'ютерні ігри
я думаю, що це приблизно все з цього списку
так,
добре, давайте подивимося на деякі
слова та перекладемо їх
так, звичайно, тому що деякі слова
можуть бути незнайомі нашим студентам
добре, що таке своїми руками, е, є  три
літери
так, а у верхньому лівому куті о, я
думаю, що це
зроби це сам я думаю, я думаю, так,
так, це щось із
рукоділлям правильно добре добре,
гм, гончарство в ньому є щось з
мистецтвом, я думаю,
так, це тип мистецтва, так, коли  ви
створюєте горщики
своїми руками і глиною, що таке глина,
глина, як
ви, ви можете зробити щось схоже на те,
кого ви знаєте, так, і це для того, щоб
ви могли робити тарілки, все це правильно,
так що це кераміка, так
добре, добре, гм, а
те, що шиє, е, шиє, це те, що
зазвичай роблять жінки, і це судиться з
чимось, е, якийсь одяг, можливо, правильно,
що вам насправді потрібно шити
цю крихітну залізну річ, яка має нитку
, я не пам'ятаю голку  це
не  edle о так правильно
я думав, що це інше для шиття
і
потрібна голка голка є голка добре я думав
голки для ін'єкцій але
це голка для шиття у нас так
само українською так що добре добре
добре і гм остання  що ми
зупинимося на цьому слові волонтерство,
що таке
еволюція, що таке волонтерство, як ви можете
пояснити це своїми словами,
ну, волонтерство дуже популярне
у Північній Америці,
це вид діяльності, який люди
роблять безкоштовно  не отримують за
це гроші, і
вони просто роблять щось
для спільнот
для інших людей,
просто з доброю волі. Добре, як ви
називаєте людину, яка
насправді займається волонтерством,
волонтером, це правильно,
добре  ну насправді, коли ми подивимося на
визначення Кембриджського словника,
будь ласка,
прочитайте його вголос, волонтер – це людина,
яка робить
щось особливо, допомагаючи іншим
людям крилатими й дотепними  їх
примушують або платять за це, тому цих людей не примушують
робити це так, вони не отримують
гроші
для себе, просто вони хочуть це
зробити, тому це їхня власна воля,
так, вони хочуть зробити щось добре,
так, вони хочуть  щоб змінити щось
на краще,
добре на дошці, ми також можемо побачити деякі
з прикладів, давайте
прочитаємо їх вголос. О, клініка
покладається на волонтерів, які керують офісом
і відповідають на
телефонні дзвінки, так,
оскільки це було б дуже  небезпечна
місія, яку
латун запросив про волонтерів, і найкраща
– це добровольча армія без оплачуваних
професіоналів, так,
тож ось приклади зі словом
волонтер
добре, а тепер давайте подивимося на цю
картинку,
гм, ви впізнаєте цю молоду леді
чи знаєте ви, хто  вона так, я думаю
, що
її звуть Грета Тонберг,
добре, так, вона молода дівчина зі Швеції,
яка насправді волонтер,
який бореться за
навколишнє середовище, щоб врятувати
планету, і вона wo  стурбована
зміною клімату, я думаю, так, так, так що
вона активістка
зі Швеції, і чому, на вашу думку, її
діяльність
важлива для світу і
планети для людей, на
мою думку, тому що вона молода жінка, і
вона є прикладом для них  діти
для підлітків, я б сказав, тому що
їй зараз 17, так,
вона є хорошим прикладом
того, що робити і що ми можемо зробити, і
для нашої місії наша відповідальність, що
ми можемо зробити,
щоб допомогти цій
екологічній місії
зберегти, я б сказав  я не знаю, так, тому
вона намагається зробити світ
кращим, і вона змушує людей
звертати увагу на проблеми екології,
зміни клімату і так далі
так, так, дуже дякую, і
добре, що вона робить це
в такому молодому віці  вік, і я думаю, що вона робить
це
вже кілька років, так, вона зараз
ми збираємося з'ясувати
, скільки років вона займається я
читав на BBC
я думаю, що, можливо, кілька років тому про неї,
коли вона тільки починала  і вона зробила велику
новину  робила те, що вона зробила так добре
добре дякую, було дуже
інформативно, дуже приємно, що ви
знаєте факти про Грету Тонберг, а тепер давайте
подивимося
на текст про Грету, і
ваше завдання - прочитати його вголос
уважно прочитати та послухати клімат
активістку Грету Томберг
назвали людиною року за версією журналу Time
у 2019
році. 16-річна жінка зі Швеції перемогла
прем'єр-міністра
Нової Зеландії Джасінду Ардерн і
протестувальників проти демократії Гонконгу, щоб
здобути славу в 2018 році за
підняття людей
про загрозу для планети від зміни
клімату
вона розпочала глобальний рух, коли в серпні 2018 року
вирішила оголосити кліматичний страйк
біля шведського
парламенту,
школярі по всьому світу, а потім
наслідували її приклад
, відтоді вона звернулася до Об’єднаних
Націй у Нью-Йорку  і зустріла Папу,
почувши про нагороду, вона
написала в Твіттері, це неймовірно, я поділю цю велику честь, о, Грета Тонберг  Наймолодша людина, яка
коли-небудь отримувала своє слово,
журнал Time написав про те, чому він
присудив премію місіс Стейнберг
, сказав, що їй вдалося створити
глобальну
зміну ставлення, залучивши мільйони
людей приєднатися до всесвітнього руху, який
закликає до невідкладних
змін, який він додав, запропонував Грета
моральний заклик до тих, хто готовий
діяти і ганьбити тих,
хто не всі задоволені тим, що
міс Стейнберг отримала слово,
Дональд Трамп-
молодший сказав, що час використовував підлітка як
маркетинговий трюк,
на відміну від Хілларі Клінтон, написала в твіттері, що
я  Я вдячний, що
вона зробила для підвищення обізнаності про
клімачну кризу
та її готовність розповісти жорстку
мотивуючу правду,
чудова робота добре, тепер, коли ви
прочитали текст так,
ми з’ясували, коли саме
Грета Тонгберг почала свою
діяльність, так, так це насправді сталося
два роки тому  добре,
тепер наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб зіставити слова
з тексту з їх визначеннями,
тож тут ми маємо десять слів
зліва
та визначення, які
Пояснення праворуч,
тож давайте спершу подивимося на слова,
а
потім порівняємо їх із визначеннями,
тому
прочитайте слова від одного до десяти, будь ласка,
протестувальник демократії,
усвідомлення, постріл зміна
терміновий трюк криза сорому
рух добре добре і  тепер давайте розглянемо
визначення за визначенням одне за одним, і
давайте прочитаємо перше пояснення, і,
до речі, чи всі слова
вам зрозумілі о так, звичайно, добре, тоді
вам буде легко зіставити їх
з визначеннями
так, добре, давайте прочитаємо
визначення перше визначення так,
правильно, дурний трюк, щоб привернути
увагу до
реклами чи бізнесу
підліток як трюк для
такого
для такої речі правильно добре дуже
добре
добре добре давайте перейдемо до визначення, а
знання чи розуміння
чогось, я думаю,
це буде усвідомлено
якщо ми говоримо, що ми щось знаємо, ми говоримо, що ми щось знаємо,
ми говоримо, що
я усвідомлюю,
так, а знання – це усвідомлення, так
добре, давайте перейдемо до третього визначення, гм, це
серйозно потребує негайних заходів або
уваги,
можливо, терміново, звичайно, звичайно  це
терміново
добре наступне визначення, ех,
зміна позиції або мислення,
так що це буде зміна, звичайно,
так, це слово зміна добре, давайте перейдемо
до наступного:
людина, яка виходить на вулицю, щоб
сказати уряду чи іншій
організації, що вони з чимось не згодні
це протестуючий, звісно,
аз ff раптово та
видко стріляє, звичайно, добре, до
ре, добре, що ви зд
гадалися, що
одо си
теми уряду Gaga, де люди го
осують за своїх лідерів, зв
чайно, це демократія, це де
ократія, це
обре, це добре  мати одне так, добре,
наступне
визначення час великих труднощів, неприємностей або
небезпеки,
так що, звичайно, тут буде криза,
добре, це кр
це втрата поваги чи поваги
безчестя це сором
, це сором,
група людей, які працюють разом заради
своїх
спільних політичних соціальних або мистецьких
ідей,
і я думаю, що це важко,
це дуже важко, це найскладніша
частина цієї вправи
так, так, це як  рух так,
безперечно, це правильно
, це добре, я спробую вгадати, і ви
дуже добре спробували
так добре добре, велике дякую, тому
тепер, коли ми зіставили слова
та визначення,
давайте переглянемо зміст тексту і переглянемо
інформацію, яка  ми читали про
Ґрету Сонберг, тому ми повинні сказати,
чи є твердження істинні чи хибні,
тому t означає істина f для хибної добре
добре, давайте подивимося на перше
твердження, гм ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб сказати,
чи є воно істинним  або false, якщо це
хибно,
було б чудово, якщо ви збережете
приклад із тексту, наприклад,
якщо ви виправите речення добре добре,
давайте спробуємо,
так що Грег Томберг переміг
прем'єр-міністра Нової Зеландії, щоб
отримати  премія, це правда,
вона зробила добре, вона насправді зробила так,
вона фактично
перемогла прем'єр-міністра Нової Зеландії, щоб зробити
це добре, а
як щодо наступного, е, Грета Танберг
стала
відомою в 2017 році. Це неправда, тому що
вона почала свою діяльність у 2018 році.
так, це було дуже  круто, це
був 2018 два роки тому, коли
Ґрета вперше з'явилася на публіці зі своїми
заявами, добре, третій, ну,
більший ліс став відомим після того, як оголосив
страйк
біля її школи, я думаю, що це
нерозумно здогадуватися,
тому я просто не пам'ятаєш  я просто
не пам'ятаю, це нормально,
так, насправді ця помилка, тому що
вона страйкувала
біля парламенту, шведського
парламенту, а не школи
, тому я цього не пам'ятаю, і
тому її фактично
помітив уряд  так
добре, добре, четверте, що
Папа зустрів Грету Тангберг, це правда,
і ви були дуже здивовані цим
фактом, так, так, а-а-а,
але це велика честь
o до п'ятого Грета
є другою наймолодшою людиною, яка отримала на
ороду за час, я д
маю, що вона була першою, та
що це неправда, добре, правильно, у вас хороші ча
и, сказала, що міс Стейнберг зм
нила думки мільйонів людей, це
правда, звичайно, це правда, та
вона справила
на них величезний вплив
, син
Дональда Трампа сказав, що дати
Греті ціну було трюком.
зробила заяву, що
вона насправді добре виконує свою роботу
, це правильно
ґрета стала
відомою у 2018 році, це правильно,
так добре, гм, за межами якої будівлі
ґрета страйкувала,
ґе, шведський парламент, правильно, ти
шведський парламент,
добре, третій, що пропустив грім
скажи  вона зробила б зі своєю ціною
я не пам'ятаю не пам'ятаю ні добре
, вона сказала, що залишить це при
собі, я не думаю, що
ні, насправді вона сказала, що
поділиться цим з іншими людьми
так добре, скільки людей  молодші за
Ґрету
виграли приз, ну, жоден, вона була першою
, вона була наймолодшою, одна
хороша робота, і остання, хто сказав
, що ціна Ґрети була маркетинговим трюком,
трамп-молодший трамп-молодший.
давайте подивимося
на речення з тексту.
Наше завдання — звернути увагу на вживання
двох плюс дієслова та ing okay
yeah, тож у нас є ці слова, на які нам
потрібно звернути увагу,
виділені вони задіяні ваше завдання
— просто
прочитати  речення, перш за все,
вона розпочала глобальний рух, коли
вирішила провести кліматичний
страйк біля шведського парламенту в
2018 році,
почувши про нагороду, яку вона
написала в Твіттері,
це неймовірно, я поділю цю
велику честь,
ну, кажуть, їй це вдалося
я вдячний за все, що вона зробила для підвищення
обізнаності
про зміну клімату добре добре, велике дякую,
тепер давайте подивимося на слова,
які задіяні,
тому зроби  у нас є ing або два плюс дієслово
після дієслова
вирішити в номері один,
тому після дієслова вирішити ми зазвичай використовуємо
два плюс
дієслово вирішити зробити щось вона
вирішила піти я вирішив
назвати слово, яке насправді означає
дію,
як-от go run swim  стрибати так, так,
коли ми щось робимо, ось два плюс
чотири, це два плюс п'ять,
добре, так, гарне число два після того,
як я почув про слова, які вона
написала в Твіттері,
це неймовірно, я поділюся
цим чудовим власником, я вже прочитав це
правильно, так, ти  я вже читав це, і
давайте подивимося на першу
частину речення, виділену жирним шрифтом,
тому після таких слів, як після
перед in at out вони називаються
прийменниками, які ми зазвичай маємо, яка
форма uh  дієслово
ing або два over here ing добре, це
правильно так
добре, гм, кажуть, що вона досягла успіху
в створенні, тому у фразі успішно
створено ми також маємо прийменник, але
тепер він є
в yeah, а після нього ми маємо
форму дієслова
це правильно, добре, а потім ми знову
маємо це
після того, як у слові get
[Music]
good, добре, і номер чотири ми
маємо фразу, яку вона зробила, щоб підвищити
обізнаність так, тож ось два плюс дієслово
два плюс дієслово, коли ми говоримо про
те, що ми  робити
чомусь так, я прокинувся, щоб
щось зробити, зробити щось або я прокинувся
рано,
щоб не запізнитися
на роботу  розкрийте дужки та
поставте дієслова у правильну форму,
щоб тут ви бачили uh хмара
слів праворуч uh з дієсловами, за якими
слідує
ing, тому після таких слів, як enjoy
like adore mind закінчимо, ми будемо використовувати
слово
з ing like  насолоджуватися
чимось фі  ніш робити щось
люблю читати не люблю стрибати
уникати плавання і так далі
добре добре, давайте почнемо з першого,
тоді перший не має сенсу я не
хочу виходити сьогодні ввечері так, насправді
це правильна форма я не можу
Я не хочу
вигадувати, як вперше почути так, ну
насправді це британська фраза, яку
ви використовуєте
так, яку ви можете використати, щоб сказати, що
ви хотіли б щось зробити
або ні  я люблю робити щось, я
хочу піти в кіно сьогодні
ввечері або я не хочу виходити сьогодні
ввечері, це означає, що я не хочу цього робити
так, так, у Північній Америці я ніколи не чув
цього за
14 років о так, так, тому що  тому
що це не американська англійська, це
британська англійська,
я бачу добре, це добре знати, див.
мм-хм,
номер два, тепер вона уникала,
ну, вона уникала розповідати йому
про
свої плани, звичайно, це правильно,
тому вона уникала розповідати йому про свої
плани,
так,  наступний номер три гм я
хотів би прийти на вечірку добре
мм-хм добре, четвертий
він любить купатися ввечері,
так як ви скажете, що він
любить купатися в кінці відразу після дієслова
насолоджуйся, ми будемо використовувати
гарне число п'ять, вона продовжувала
говорити під час фільму,
відразу наступне
речення uh я вчуся говорити
англійською я вчуся говорити англійською
, це правильно,
так, коли ми навчимося робити щось, ми
використовуємо два плюс дієслово після вивчення
good uh do  ти не проти дати мені руку
, ти не проти дати мені руку так,
насправді, це дуже поширена помилка,
добре, так, ти не проти щось зробити,
тому
розум супроводжується гнівом, ти не проти
зробити щось
добре, звісно, ти можеш почути в ро
мові  англійська, що люди
кажуть, що ви не проти щось зробити, але
граматично
правильно, а для підлітків, наприклад,
які збираються
складати тести, дуже важливо
знати, що
розум робить щось добре,
навіть якщо ви питаєте людину, як у реальному часі
мені подобається
виходити з машини дівчина, яка просить хлопця
подати їй руку
Я збентежена, чи це
занадто Carrie Carone
[Музика]
вона допомогла мені нести мої валізи
так, вона допомогла мені нести мої валізи,
добре, добре, так що після дієслова
help ми можемо використовувати два плюс інфінітив, тому
допоможіть комусь щось зробити або
насправді є також
, це не помилка, якщо сказати, допоможіть
комусь зробити
щось без частки два, добре,
але в основному нам потрібно навчитися,
що за деякими дієсловами слідує
ang, а за деякими дієсловами не
слідує
два плюс інфінітив, добре,
насправді це  це на сьогодні, а
так, дуже дякую за вашу роботу,
ти дуже старанний
і розумний студент, добре, і тепер наші
студенти, наші глядачі повинні мати
домашнє завдання, тож давайте подивимося, що
вони мають написати статтю в журналі
про Gret  Тонберг, який
заслуговує на нагороду, включає уявні
інтерв'ю
з людьми, які за і проти цього,
напишіть приблизно 15 18 речень,
добре, так що це все, ми можемо почути, як
дзвонить дзвінок, о, так,
і урок закінчено, дуже дякую,
так, побачимося наступного разу
до побачення, дуже дякую
[Музика]
і
[Музика].